believe that Russell Brand is innocent
and the reason I believe Russell Brand
is innocent is I think that the woman
has every incentive to lie and the man
has zero incentives
um typically men that are having sex
thrown at them 24 7 do not have to rape
someone for sex but usually broke
post-wall women
need money I I mean money and attention
they're missing so it seems like she has
every incentive to lie
um and do the wrong thing where the
woman does it and my question is if all
of these women are coming out with
assault allegation then why aren't they
all public why was there no police
report and at the end of the day until I
see
a police report I just don't buy it